der durchbruch der hirnforschung
forscher des massachusetts institute of
technology kurz m haben das gehirn von
mäusen manipulierten diese mäuse
erinnerten sich auf befehl an positive
oder negative ereignisse ganz bestimmt
zum einen eröffnen die forschung neue
bahnbrechende therapie möglichkeiten
andererseits sind sie auch eine große
gefahr können wir in zukunft manipuliert
werden das ist jetzt das thema weg zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
übrigens on tour
manchmal habe ich echt das gefühl dass
wir in einem zeitalter leben in dem
wirklich an allen ecken und enden quasi
im minutentakt riesige fortschritte
erzielt werden aber dazu gibt es ja auch
die these dass die entwicklung durch vor
allem immer schneller fortschreitet und
technische fortschritte oder
forschungsergebnisse nur noch ein paar
tage benötigen um sich zu verbreiten und
unser hirn spielt dabei eine erhebliche
rolle denn da muss das alles verarbeitet
werden es müssen rückschlüsse gezogen
werden erkenntnisse miteinander
verknüpft werden und dass aus unseren
erinnerungen denn wissen besteht aus
erinnerung und diese können die forscher
vom jetzt manipulieren da kann ich noch
mal wieder wort ausrufen die forscher
haben eine ausgeklügelte technik
entwickelt um erstens erinnerungen ganz
gezielt abzuspeichern und sie dann per
knopfdruck abzurufen dass es wirklich
gespenst was haben die forscher gemacht
zuerst mal haben sie einen grünalgen gen
chr 2 in das erbgut eingeschleust es
kann ein licht gesteuertes protein
produzieren wenn die nervenzellen jetzt
aktiv werden produzieren sie dieses
protein und von da an können die
nervenzellen mit licht aktiviert werden
die grünen algen also aus grünalgen
gehen sehr r2 hat noch einen
entscheidenden vorteil es kann
abgeschaltet werden dann wird das
protein nicht produziert das geschieht
mit tetracyclin ist das in der nahrung
enthalten passiert genau diese
proteinproduktion nicht die forscher um
den nobelpreisträger sumo toni da war
haben jetzt folgendes gemacht
standardmäßig ist in dem futter der
mäuse tetracyclin beigemischt also es
passiert erstmal nichts im gehirn für
den versuch wird die substanz abgesetzt
jetzt ist das car2go in diesem zustand
werden sie mit einem sehr positiven
ereignisse oder einem sehr negativen
ereignis konfrontiert zum beispiel sex
mit einer anderen maus oder
elektroschocks danach wird dem futter
wieder tetracyclin beigemischt jetzt
sind die zellen mit dieser erinnerung
über das grünalgen gehen markiert in das
gehirn haben die forscher glasfasern
eingepflanzt über die sie jederzeit die
nervenzellen mit blauem blazer licht
beleuchten können geschieht das werden
die betroffenen nervenzellen in denen
genau diese erinnerungen abgespeichert
ist über das licht gesteuerte protein
aktiviert die erinnerung wird abgerufen
dass die mäuse erinnern sich durch
diesen lichtimpuls genau an dieses
ereignis das heißt dann zum beispiel
dass menschen in depressiven phasen mit
dieser technologie ganz gezielt mit
positiven erinnerungen konfrontiert
werden könnten die negativen folgen
dieser krankheit könnten so zum beispiel
dramatisch verringert werden aber wir
könnten so auch zur komplett willenlosen
wesen werden die total manipulierbar
werden da werden dann die schlimmsten
albträume wahr ja also keine videos mehr
zu solchen und anderen themen verpassen
darf ich mir ein abo aufs auge drücken
und nicht vergessen wer einen auf die
glocke zu geben und was meint ihr sollte
solche forschung verboten werden oder
zumindest unter staatliche kontrolle
gestellt werden diskutiertes in den
kommentaren ansonsten bis dahin bleibt
dran